new at 11 o'clock Las Vegas has lost one
of its own Benny the skating dog known
here at home and really across the
country for his skills on the ice has
died Sasha Loftus spoke exclusively with
his family tonight as they remember all
the lives he changed and she joins us
now with this story you'll only see on 8
News Now
Benny the ice skating dog now as his
family Grieves his sudden death his mom
Cheryl wants to honor everything he
brought to our community
from the day we got him he was perfect
Benny the ice skating dog beautiful
talented and always willing to make
anyone smile that's how he was he was
like a like a person the labrador
retriever rescued from a shelter by
Cheryl Del song wrote 10 years ago made
a name for himself here in Las Vegas and
all across the country
with his unbelievable skills on the ice
the first time we went on the ice he
could actually skate I mean it wasn't
like I had to teach him now five years
after this Wonder Dog Rose to fame Benny
died suddenly a few weeks ago at 12
years old leaving Cheryl and her whole
family devastated he was like
my best friend I feel like I lost like
my arm or something but with that
sadness also comes so much pride he had
a bigger line than the girls that that
got the medals happy memories here at
home and on trips to rinks all around
the country we skated in Central Park at
Rockefeller Center and Detroit you know
everywhere Cheryl says it's hard to
breathe without Benny but she hopes his
legacy will always live on he changed so
many lives and besides the impact just
being a dog he's also a rescue dog and
encourage others to take a chance we
should really check your local shelters
or dog rescues and see what's out there
because you could get a Benny and no the
absolute best can happen there you go he
was really an incredible dog what do you
got then huh
the Betty was featured on the dodo and
other viral sites he also won the akc's
canine Excellence award in 2021 now
Denise Cheryl has organized a special
adoption event to remember him next
weekend with the nspca you know I know
he passed a couple weekends ago and she
just wasn't ready to talk about it so I
appreciate the fact that she trusted us
with this story and he was one of the
first stories that you did when you
moved here he was I met him five years
ago right when he was starting his
skating career so he was special to me
as well so I'll miss him for sure before
he was world famous yes all right Sasha
thanks for that tonight